hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
use of a new 3d pluripotent stem cell
suspension culture medium
for rapid scale up and downstream
differentiation of pluripotent stem
cells
i am jennifer woods of lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labruz and brought to you
by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
backslash stem scale we encourage you to
participate today by submitting any
questions you may have during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit any technical issues here as
well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please follow the process to obtain your
credits by clicking on the continuing
education credits window
i'd like to know welcome our speakers
michael aikenhead ph.d
scientist 3 biosciences division at
thermo fisher scientific
and michael derr scientist 3 biosciences
division at thermo fisher scientific
dr michael aikenhead will be present for
the first half of this presentation
followed by his colleague michael durr
dr aikenhead you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for the introduction so i will
be starting by
going over how we're using our new 3d
pluripotent stem cell suspension culture
medium
called spin scale for the rapid scale up
and down stream differentiation of
blurry put in stencils
uh so here's a brief overview of my part
of the presentation
uh first we'll be covering briefly the
benefits of suspension culture
then we'll be discussing the gibco stem
cell psc suspension medium workflow
and then lastly i'll be focusing on some
stem scale performance data
[Music]
so first let's talk about why
researchers want to utilize suspension
culture
inherent cultures are limited by their
surface area and also by the confluency
of cells grown in that area
whereas in contrast suspension cultures
are limited by volume
instead of surface area so this enables
a higher capacity for growth and
suspension
due to increased efficiency and higher
seeding densities
so overall the main appeal of suspension
cultures is the ability to more rapidly
scale up to large numbers of cells
this can be accomplished in a shorter
period of time as you can see in the
figure at the bottom
uh calculated 19 days to achieve 4.5
billion cells in suspension
compared to adherent cultures which in
this case show 28 days to achieve the
same 4.5 billion cells
in addition suspension culture is also
less expensive than inherent culture
due to suspicion cultures utilizing less
plastics and consuming less media
in comparison to adhering cultures
although uh suspension cultures are very
appealing due to the advantages they
have over inherent cultures
there are still some technical
challenges which must be overcome
and this can be observed when comparing
two main categories here microcurrent
cultures versus spheric cultures
so the macrocarriage cultures involve
cells growing on some sort of supported
matrix
such as beads gels or other structures
and while this does enable consistent
cell growth
they tend to be time consuming to
prepare and difficult to passage
uh there's also inconsistent attachment
of cells to the macrocarriers
and overall the limited surface area on
the microcarriers can
sometimes prohibit the large scale
expansion of cells in suspension so in
contrast to the micro carriers
spheroid cultures are much more
appealing to researchers these cultures
utilize the ability of cells to
self-aggregate into floating spherital
clumps
thereby eliminating the need for solar
to grow adhered to a macro carrier
substrate
while this does simplify the initiation
of suspension cultures there are still
some drawbacks to the spheroid culture
particularly related to current
solutions
in particular it's difficult to regulate
the aggregate size
and growth across multiple different psc
lines in order to achieve consistency
additionally uh some current solutions
have a relatively low fold expansion and
cell number
making scaling up to large numbers more
difficult
and lastly uh oftentimes there are
cumbersome workflows involved with
spheroid cultures
requiring the use of self-trainers or
other components that make it more
difficult to easily passage
so we took all these factors into
account we wanted to come up
with a suspension culture medium that
can maximize the expansion capability of
cells
and simplify the workflow while overall
maintaining their pluripotency
so to accomplish this we came up with
the stem scale suspension medium
and we focused on these um main
components when designing stem scale
we wanted to make expansion efficient
thereby optimizing steroid nucleation in
order to promote efficient growth
uh we also wanted to simplify the
workflow so to do this
we focused on enabling periodic medium
exchanges uh and focusing on the ability
to passage cells without the need for
extra components like cell strainers
we also wanted to have consistent
scalable cultures
across multiple sized vessels and also
the ability to maintain
cells as pluripotent when they're grown
in steroids
and lastly we wanted to generate high
quality pfcs
capable of being used for downstream
applications such as differentiation
protocols
so now we'll briefly discuss the stem
scale workflow here
so here's the stem scale workflow at a
glance this workflow involves
seeding of 3d culture vessels on day
zero
and after seeding uh we utilize the 50
medium exchange
in order to feed cultures every other
day
this replacement strategy prevents the
accumulation of waste in the suspension
culture
and also contributes to the maintenance
of a consistent steroid size
since steroids will be grown in a
constant volume for the duration of the
culture
and as i mentioned the 50 medium
replacement strategy illustrated here
is an every other day feed although you
can feed cells
daily in order to maximize their
viability
um so in the example here for an every
other day feed we are skipping feeding
on day two
and day four in order to passage cells
on day five
uh this is a typical uh five-day
passaging schedule but you can pass
itself on day four as well
or even as early as day three if you
want to avoid passaging on the weekend
[Music]
so in addition to stem scale medium
there are some other components that are
necessary
to have as well it's also important to
have an orbital shaker platform that can
be placed into a cell incubator
the stem pro accutase passaging reagent
in the desired vessel which will be used
to grow suspension cultures so for the
desired vessel
we recommend non-tissue culture treated
plates um
if you're using well plates or a plain
bottom flask
that is non-baffled if you're using some
sort of shaped flask
so with all these materials in place
you're ready to initiate these stem
scale cultures
these cultures can easily be seeded from
existing adherent cultures
and once your adherent culture is around
60 to 80 percent confluent
then you can dissociate them using the
stembro accutase passenger reagent
and then feed them into your desired
desired vessel of choice
uh the recommended seating that's the is
a hundred fifty thousand cells per ml
although you can see it at a lower
density
and when seeding cells it's also
important direct uh to remember to
include a rock inhibitor
we recommend using y27632 but the rock
inhibitors
uh are possible as well without the rock
inhibitor present
you'll find that the cell will not
spontaneously aggregate together into
these spheroidal clumps
now after seeing the suspension cultures
on day zero the cultures will need to be
fed on the subsequent day
and because these suspension cultures
have formed steroids overnight we can
use gravity sedimentation to collect
steroids at the bottom of the well or
the flask
thereby enabling medium exchange from
the top of the vessel
the gravity sedimentation should occur
for approximately five minutes
in order to minimize the amount of time
the steroids been clumped at the bottom
of the well
because the cereal has remained um
sedimented for too long then they will
begin to aggregate to each uh aggregate
to each other and form these undesirable
clumps
this can also occur if the steroids are
removed from agitation for an extended
period of time
such as when you're imaging steroids
under a microscope so it's important to
try to minimize the amount of time
that plates or flasks are removed from
an orbital shaker platform
so no longer than 15 minutes is a good
recommendation
so to accomplish uh performing the 50
medium replacement
uh 50 medium replacement for the roll
plates you can tilt the wall plate at a
45 degree angle and then wait five
minutes for the steroids to settle
for the shake flasks uh you can simply
remove this flask from the orbital
shaker platform and then just let the
spheroids fall to the center of the
vessel
then after five minutes you simply
remove half of the medium on the spent
medium that is
and then replace with an equal line of
fresh medium
once this is done you can just move the
plate or the flask back onto the shake
platform
so overall the 50 medium strategy is
very beneficial
for suspension cultures uh because it's
very simple to perform
uh only relying on the gravity
sedimentation of the 3d spheroids
additionally because the 50 medium
replacement strategy has an equal volume
of fresh medium
every time you're removing the spent
medium this ensures the culture volume
remains constant for the duration of the
suspension filter
and because spheroid size is affected by
the shear force applied to the system
by maintaining a constant volume you're
ensuring that the spheroids are always
being suspended and exposed to the same
shear thereby ensuring that their size
remains consistent over the duration of
the culture
and most importantly the 50 medium
replacement strategy will prevent the
accumulation of waste products
over the duration of the culture um
other types of feed strategies
such as batch feeding processes which
just add fresh medium to the existing
spin medium
we'll see metabolic waste products that
keep light far more rapidly compared to
this replacement strategy
[Music]
so in order to package the um steps
legal
cultures we utilize stem pro accutase
this is also a very simple process once
the spheroids are ready to be passaged
they're transferred into a conical tube
we then centrifuge the conical tube in
order to aspirate the supernatant
and then add the stem scale passaging
reagent for about 10 minutes
over this 10 minute duration you can see
the spheroids begin to break apart
as gentle agitation is applied to the
tube
[Music]
so after the duration of the 10 minutes
the steroids should be completely broken
apart
into very tiny chunks making them uh
nearly invisible to the eye
so then you can place them in the
centrifuge spin them down and then
prepare them for counting
and if you've obtained your cell counts
and you can use them for subsequent
downstream applications
or receive them back into suspension
vessels for subsequent passages
so this passaging protocol has several
benefits to researchers looking for a
simple protocol
most importantly there's no need to
utilize cell strainers or microcarriers
in this passaging protocol cell
strainers tend to be cumbersome to use
can often damage cells and you can often
even lose cells
as you're passing them through the cell
strainer
additionally since we're simply using
actually takes with no cell strainer
there's limited manipulation that's
required
reducing the risk of contamination
[Music]
there are also a few additional
experimental variables which can be used
to manipulate
and control spheroid size in the roof
the most important is the shaker
platform rpm
as you see here shaker platform rpm is
inversely related to spheroid size
so by increasing the platform rpm you'll
have
smaller steroids as a result the images
on the right
shifter is on day one at 70 rpm compared
to spheroids on day one at 90 rpm
and you can see at 90 rpm the spheroids
are much smaller compared to at 70.
uh in a similar fashion uh as i
mentioned how the the shear force
is important to the steroid size on the
previous slides uh culture vessel volume
will also affect the spheroid sides
and it's directly related so at 30 ml of
media
in the shake flask the steroids will be
smaller than grown at 40 mils of media
lastly seating that city is another
variable on this one by
uh increasing the seating density you'll
obtain a larger number of steroids
or a greater number of steroids in your
suspension culture
but it's important not to increase seed
density too high as with
more steroids forming and expanding in
suspension the media will also be
consumed in a much more rapid pace
[Music]
so now that we've discussed the skin
cell stem cell stem scale protocol
i would like to demonstrate its
performance with some experimental data
here
uh so on this slide here we see that
stem scale promotes the rapid expansion
of cells in suspension
so you can see a representative image of
our gibko observable ipsc's in the upper
left
and this is how the steroids will appear
after five days of growth to the stem
scale medium
the two graphs shown here represent
their growth in either well plates
or larger vessels of varying sizes and
you can see that we obtain
an average of approximately 10-fold
expansion whether they're grown in small
blow plates
larger shake flasks or even larger
bioreactors
so this indicates that stem scale does
promote expansion
and consistent expansion across a
variety of different
vessel sizes
[Music]
and in addition to high expansion
potential
we see that stem scale also maintains
pluripotent cells over multiple passages
also on this slide i'm showing the good
cobismal ipscs
and wa09 efcs which are h9 cells
exhibit over 90 percent expression of
opt for nanomob pluripotency markers
uh as assessed after five passages
suspension
uh we further confirmed this through the
use of our plury test assay
uh indicating that cells from our 3d
spheroids all remain pluripotent and
distinct from non-ipsc controls
and we also confirmed that these cells
obtained after pi passages will maintain
a normal karyotype
as assessed through the kerystad assay
there were no chromosomal aberrations
detected after five passages in
suspension so together
this shows that stem scale can both
enhance full change uh and maintain the
pluripotency
of cells grown spheroids
now this slide i had shown for five
passages
but we also have data uh over multiple
consecutive passages for gibco abnormal
ipscs
and in this case we grew them out 30
consecutive passages in suspension
and then did the same performance tests
and so as you can see
uh the graph on the upper left after 30
passages in suspicion they have the same
over 90 percent expression of oxford
nano markers
uh they also passed the pluri test assay
after
passage 30 and again showed no
chromosomal aberrations
uh as determined by the curious stat
assay
although i don't have the data shown
here we also performed
um we also ran the cells on the alkamine
assay to look for specific oncogenic
mutations
and saw that none were none were
detected
and lastly the graph on the bottom right
shows that
the cell line will maintain consistent
growth over 30 consecutive passages
as we have a nice straight line with
each data point representing one passage
indicating that we get approximately
eight to ten-fold expansion per passage
[Music]
in order to prevent the formation of a
necrotic core when growing
cells of spheroids it's important to
passage the steroids
when the average diameter reaches a
certain size we found that passaging
spheroids when the average diameter is
approximately 400 microns
will prevent the formation of this
necrotic core
so when you're growing uh cells as
spheroids in our stem scale medium
we found that this can occur on either
day four and day five of culture
on day four the average diameter is less
than 400 microns
uh well on day five it's right at or
slightly above 400 microns
so users can choose to passage either
day four or day five depending on
their cell uh their needs for cellules
you can also choose the passage on day
three if necessary uh such as if day
three is falling on a friday
and you'd rather not passage on a
saturday or sunday
uh but uh if you're passaging on day
three the cell yield will be lower
due to the limited expansion time that
these cells have had compared to a day
for day five culture
now all the previous data that i've
shown has been utilizing give coposomal
ipsc
cells or h9
the wa9 cells is listed but i'd like to
show that stem scale is compatible with
a variety of different cell lines as
well
so on this slide i've got a comparison
between four cell lines
including the previously mission ones
also wtc11 ipscs
and w801 escs which are h1 cells
and although i don't have the data
displayed here when we are doing alpha
testing with our media
our alpha tester is also evaluated with
their own in-house lines
so we've evaluated a total of 10
different cell lines as well
so if you look on the graph on the
bottom left you can see the
expansion potential of all four cell
lines
all of them are showing consistent
growth over three consecutive passages
uh but what i want to point out is that
the uh full change
the expansion potential of each cell
line and suspension will be different
uh depending on how easily the cells
form spheroids
so for the gibco abnormal ipscs and the
wtc11 cells
they tend to form spheroids easily so
they have a much higher fold change
compared to the wa9 or the wa01 cells
which have more difficulty nucleating
and forming spheroids
and so they will have a lower full
change as a result
[Music]
so on this slide i'd like to show how
stem scale
performs compared to some other media
that are currently available
that are marketed as suspension culture
media
so we evaluated our stem scale media
against another type of media
and you see the cells on the upper left
our stem scale spheroids tend to be
larger
than the spheroids obtained from the
other medium and when you look at the
resulting pole change over three
consecutive passages
we see that for our git co-absorbable
ipscs we're averaging approximately
11-fold expansion per passage
whereas using the other medium our gib
codes will only average approximately
five-fold expansion per passage
uh the uh graph on the upper right shows
the oct4 and
nano expression for both media and we
see that it's the same
um 90 expression so this indicates
that our stem scale medium is capable of
outperforming
in terms of growth of the other medium
while still maintaining pluripotent
cells over the course of these three
consecutive passages
and so while i've been showing how stem
scale is optimized for suspension
culture
and mention learning how it enables you
to scale up the larger numbers of cells
uh and in addition to showing how it
outperforms the other media on the
previous slide
i do want to emphasize uh that this is
not because stem scale is causing cells
to divide more rapidly than what is
observed
in hearing cultures uh when you compare
the growth rates of adherence cells
grown in stem flicks
um the bottom left graph again stems
against spheroids that are grown in stem
scale
we see that their population doubling
times are similar
so this indicates that the rates of
expansion are equivalent and it's
actually the benefits of the suspension
culture system
which support the ability to generate
large numbers of cells
so when we optimize stem scale we
optimize this ability to nucleate
and to efficiently grow spheroids to
ensure we can take advantage of the
suspension culture benefits
as i mentioned in the introduction uh
because of here cultures eliminated by
surface area and by a rigid
passaging schedule dictated by
confluency they're unable to
achieve these large numbers of cells
whereas suspension cultures
are limited by volume and with this
extra dimension they can support higher
numbers of cells to be taken into
cultures and because steroid size is
what regulates the packaging schedule
this is much more flexible than
confluency can allow cultures to grow
for longer periods of time
thereby ultimately enable a rapid
scaling up
using the same population doubling time
and since i've been talking about being
able to scale up to large volumes
on this slide i want to show that we've
been able to scale up to a three liter
bioreactor system
using stem scale media so the images on
the left
are from steroids used in 125 mil shake
flasks
small 100 mil bioreactor and then the
large 300 liter via or three liter
bioreactor
and the graph in the middle shows the uh
full change results that we obtained
and we achieved about an 11 fold
expansion in the three liter bar reactor
uh with our [ __ ] co-op zonal ipscs which
is very similar
for what we've seen among the previous
slides
i do want to point out the uh the two
bar graphs
or the the two bars for the 100 ml
bioreactor and 125 mil stake flask
are a little lower than the three liter
bioreactor this is because i was
sampling
uh daily from all these cultures and
steroids were being removed as a result
so without daily sampling i would
anticipate that
all three vessels would have very
similar expansion
we were able to obtain a total of
approximately five billion gift
co-absorbable ipsc cells
using this expansion in the three liter
bioreactor system
[Music]
so with the uh cells that we obtained
from the three liter bioreactor system
uh we wanted to see how we could put
them to use for downstream applications
so while michael ander will be
explaining how they can be used for
differentiation
on this slide i wanted to see about
cryopreserving large numbers of cells
so once we disassociated the spheroids
into single cells
we preserve them at high densities from
5 million cells per ml
up to 40 million cells per ml
then we placed them in liquid nitrogen
over a period of time
and then removed the cryopreserved vials
and thawed
and the cells directly into suspension
cultures
so we observed that during the first
passage that cells were expanding in
suspension
after being removed directly from cryo
preservation
they did require a recovery passage
where the blue bar
represents the expansion in the first
passage this blue bar is
significantly lower compared to what we
normally see
but in subsequent passages once the
cells have recovered
in passages two and three we see high
expansion similar to what we have
observed on the previous slides so this
indicates that
once you've scaled up to a large number
of themselves you can try to preserve
them at a variety of different seating
densities
and then follow them directly into
suspension only requiring a single
recovery
passage
and since i did mention previously that
some cell lines have difficulty
forming spheroids in suspension uh due
to this recovery passage i wanted to see
if we could
uh improve the ability for cells to come
out of cryo
and then form spheroids and suspension
and by doubling the initial seeding
density from our recommendation of 150
000 cells per mil
to 300 000 cells per mil we observe that
more spheroids are obtained during the
recovery passage
where the full change remains the same
so this indicates that we're
uh achieving more steroids that are
growing at the same rate
and when you take those spheroids at the
higher density and then feed them into
subsequent passages at our standard
seating density uh we see again
the same expansion potential compared to
the previous slides as well
so this indicates that if you would like
yourselves to recover better
uh coming straight from cryo
preservation you can see it at a higher
seeding density
during the first passage recovery and
then return to our standard density of
the subsequent passages
so here are the key takeaways that i'd
like you to remember
um we've shown that stem scale psc
suspension medium has a simplified
workflow for suspension culture
which does not require use of micro
carriers or cell strainers
we've shown that our medium is scalable
across multiple multiple culture nestle
formats
from the small scale well plates up to
the large scale three liter fire
reactors
our medium optimizes the nucleation of
chloroplast and stem cells into
spheroids
which enables efficient growth uh over
multiple passages in suspension
and it also maintains the pluripotency
of cells that are expanded spheroids
uh across multiple passages and as
you'll see on the upcoming slides
michael der show how it supports
downstream differentiation as 3d
spheroids
[Music]
so thank you very much for listening to
my part of the presentation
and i would like to pass it over now to
michael dear
[Music]
thank you michael
um and yes today i will be talking about
senscal psc suspension medium
differentiation applications
and okay so the my presentation
objectives to introduce examples
of suspension culture differentiation
applications that we have developed
demonstrate the benefits of suspension
culture differentiation
compared to traditional monolayer
provide guidance and key parameters for
optimizing differentiation in suspension
culture
and highlight the features of psd
spheroids cultured and stem scales that
are beneficial for
differentiating in suspension culture
and uh before i get into my examples
i'd like to point out that we have
several guidance documents
for suspension culture differentiation
applications at
stensky or thermofisher.com stemscale
including application notes and
protocols much of what
i'm going to be presenting today can be
found
in much more detail within these
documents
all right so going on to uh
the first applications i'm going to
present are used using psc neural
induction medium which
generates neural stem cells and the psc
dopaminergic neuron differentiation kit
which generates
specific dopaminergic neurons of the
midbrain that are
important for parkinson's disease
research
and these differentiation mediums were
originally developed for monolayer
culture
and here i optimized the protocols for
differentiation
in suspension culture so
uh just to give you an overall sort of
introduction to these uh protocols
if we start at the schematic on top
[Music]
i will kind of walk through the protocol
so first the cells are plated in some
scale medium and cultured for
two days to form spheres and then
next the the induction step and the
expansion step are carried out
in a suspension culture followed by
accutane dissociation
and plating in plating the cells
in monolayer for neuronal maturation
and then going down to the second
schematic the the dopaminergic neuron
differentiation protocol is very similar
to the initial
neural induction protocol so the the
specification and expansion
steps are also done in suspension
culture followed by maturation
in monolayer so this strategy
kind of takes advantage of the
suspension culture
environment and results in increased
yields of nfcs
and progenitor cells from these
particular protocols
so the the suspension culture
differentiation carried out in
is carried out in conditions very
similar to
the typical stem scale psc culture
meaning that the the agitation speeds
and the the medium volumes
are the same for the corresponding
vessels
that are used and these parameters
are usually needed to be
optimized for differentiation protocols
so um
having this guidance really saves a lot
of time
and uh kind of gives you a feel for how
to do these protocols as well
and then the suspension culture benefits
[Music]
include shortened protocol skewers
association steps
and less hands-on time compared to the
monolayer protocol
so uh what do these protocols kind of
look like during the differentiation and
expansion
um here on the left
we show the neural induction protocol
and kind of what the cell agar gets
looked like during induction and
expansion
so during induction the cell aggregates
uh can be seen on top
and they form these sort of complex
uh lobular-like structures that have an
epithelial epithelial-like
morphology and as they continue to
grow uh they start to kind of break off
into these smaller aggregates
which can be seen on the top left that
they are top right at day six
um and then this this process continues
during
uh expansion and this prevents the size
of the aggregates from getting too large
and this is actually quite convenient
and
[Music]
is why there's only a single
dissociation
step um during both of these protocols
and
um dissociation
is not necessary for uh during induction
or the expansion stages
um in the middle i have an image so you
can see
uh what the aggregates kind of look like
in the six well plates
and a 500 mil flask format
uh we have protocols for both the 6-well
plate
as well as scaling up for the larger
flask formats
the six-volt plates are quite convenient
for optimization experiments or
for your you're doing these protocols
for the first time
um it's a good thing to do it in in
smaller scale before scaling up and
using
large quantities of medium and then
um on the right i'm showing that you
know instead of dissociating the cell
aggregates
uh during expansion we
these aggregates are you know
continuously getting more cells and
aggregates that are
growing and sort of blebbing off but
we recommend distributing uh the the
intact aggregates
uh for example one two three into
multiple vessels
um so that you aren't just going through
medium too fast and
sort of having to change uh the medium
daily so that's
kind of how we get around the not uh
dissociating
the aggregates and i'll
go into just a little bit more detail
okay so now uh comparing the the
suspension culture differentiation
protocol
to uh the monolayer protocol by first
looking at their workflows
we see that the monolayer protocol is
significantly longer
we recommend going into neuronal
maturation after 24 days
compared to 16 days with the suspension
culture and i will show an example of
why this
is in a later slide but um
additionally as i briefly stated earlier
they're uh much more dissociation steps
in the monolayer protocol so there's
five dissociation sets compared to
to only one uh for the suspension
culture
protocol um so right the the duration
and hands-on time is is decreased
significantly for the
suspension culture protocols
and next um we're
comparing performance um so induction
efficiency
is quite equivalent for both of the
protocols
in that you achieve over ninety percent
um sox1 positive nfcs
and then comparing expansion uh the
suspension culture protocol
yields much more cells
so by day 12
you have uh twice as many nses and
this kind of trend continues uh
throughout
expansion as you get more and more self
so um
there's equivalent induction efficiency
and
improved expansion in the suspension
culture protocol
all right now comparing the maturation
in the suspension and monolayer so
here um i looked at three different
groups
of nses and plated them in maturation
medium
so on the right um
and and this is why we we recommend a
longer
monolayer protocol uh here uh
that will be uh illustrated so first we
have nfcs from
day 16 of the monolayer protocol
and that's in the red in the
corresponding time points
can be seen on the left in the red with
the red star
so after
seven days of maturing these nfcs you
can see that there
are a lot of flattened out cells and
these cells are proliferative
and then continuing continuing on
vertically down that column you can see
that
at day 20 of maturation these
cultures result in
large amounts of clumps and low neuronal
purity
and then so you can compare that
condition to
the middle one which is monolayer mscs
taken from day 24
and go going into maturation and then
also
on the right you have suspension culture
protocol nfcs
from day 16. and
you see that the nfc's efficiently
go into maturation and after 20 days
they achieve highly pure neuronal
populations
so so to achieve the equivalent results
in in monolayer more time is required
so basically suspension culture day 16
nscs go into maturation
equivalent to day 24 nfc
and of the monolayer that extra time is
actually
required to achieve that efficiency in
the monolayer
okay so now going to uh the dopaminergic
neuron differentiation kit
um i will show an example of optimizing
the size of the psd spheroid
um so looking at
the the protocol you can see that we
recommend culturing
stem scale as pfcs for two days
before starting differentiation and in
this example we compared
spheroids that were in scale for two
days or three days
and put both of those into maturation
or into differentiation and
the difference between these is that
just that the spheroids are larger
in the psd day three uh stem scale
condition
so there's a larger sphere size at the
start of differentiation for the psc
day three and
what we found is that the larger
spheroids resulted in
significantly lower specification
efficiency and
as can be seen with the the decrease
otx2 expression
in the icc images in the middle
and then it's also quantified on the
right so we did
a quantitative icc
looking at fox coexpression of otx2 and
the the larger sphere size uh
starting psd steroids resulted in
significantly
decreased uh quantitation of the
uh box ato and ogx2 so
these were not appropriately specified
to
foreplay progenitors and
continuing on through maturation you can
also see that this resulted in
significantly lower th
expressing toxicity positive midbrain
neurons
so um pfc sphere size
at the start of differentiation is a
critical parameter to optimize
for differentiation protocols and this
was just an example for this one but
optimal sphere size for differentiation
may vary with with different protocols
as well as different psd lines
and i will show you some examples of
that
as well in the coming slides so
uh continuing with the dopaminergic
neuron differentiation
um yes here i am
comparing the
monolayer to suspension culture and just
looking at the the protocol schematic
at the top you can see that um
again the suspension culture protocol
requires uh
significantly fewer days so um
the time to go into maturation
uh the suspension culture requires 14
days
whereas the
monolayer protocol requires 21 days and
again one dissociation is suspension
culture
compared to three for the monolayer
and then two further
compare the suspension culture and
monolayer protocol
performance we compared the functional
maturation
of the resulting dopaminergic neurons
from each protocol using
two different pfc lines and so to do
this we plated
the cells for maturation on
multi-electrode array flights
from axiom biosciences which
allows us to monitor the the spontaneous
functional activity
and as well as the networked activity
over time
and so what we found is that the neurons
from the suspension culture at
suspension culture protocol showed
earlier
onset of spontaneous activity and
networked activity as well as
they also sustained higher levels of the
activity over time
so this this would indicate that the the
suspension culture results in
um more efficient maturation
similar to what the neural induction
protocol showed as well as
um functional maturation of these cells
okay so moving on to another
application so my colleague richard
josephson
has done a lot of work on uh generating
cardiomyocytes from
uh the stem scale psc spheroids and
there is and we have an app note on
online for this as well as a protocol
and um
i just wanted to highlight a few
um a few key points on
on this uh slide so
the first one being so the ps for for
this particular protocol
um optimal mesodermal induction was
achieved
with psc day 4 spheroids so
this is an example of
a protocol requiring a different size of
pscs at the start and the middle
uh panel you can see the relative gene
expression from
the different size of steroids uh
starting steroids and what he found
was that um using the psc day four
spheroids resulted in
the highest level of induction of these
of these mesodermal
and cardiomyocyte markers after the
induction
step um so this is a good example of
you know depending on what protocol
you're using you may need
a different size uh psd spheroids and
um another key point of optimization
for this protocol here was uh
it requires lower agitation speeds
during maturation because the
um cardiomyocyte spheroids
during maturation become quite fragile
so that may that's another thing to keep
in mind when you're
sort of optimizing these essential goals
or protocols is
decreasing the the agitation speed um
is more gentle on the cell but if you
see cells breaking up you can kind of
adjust the speed
uh to kind of compensate for that and
um for these protocols uh he found that
beating carmichael beating
cardiomyocytes were observed
between day 7 and day 14.
and the final application uh that i'm
going to present today
is uh generating midbrain organoids from
scale psd steroids and again this was
done using the psd dopaminergic neuron
differentiation kit
which again was originally developed for
cutie culture and
richard optimized this for 3d culture
or for organoid generation and
um this is
another example of a different size of
psd spheroids being required to start
the
the differentiation protocol so for this
one uh we
actually recommend recommends using uh
psd day one spheroids and
this is really kind of a benefit of
the sun scale media and its improved
nucleation
um of these steroids so even by day one
of being in stem scale you get quite
robust steroids so they're able to go
into differentiation protocols
and this is not true for a lot of other
media
suspension culture psc media that
we've tested
so um i'd also like to point out that
there is a webinar available
libraries webinar by richard josephson
called
3d organoid models for differentiation
of psd derived
dopaminergic neurons so you can also
check that out
if you are looking for more information
and we also have a protocol for this
online
and a few more details about this so the
the dopaminergic
neurons can be observed in these
organoids by
day 22 so after about three weeks
and then also you can see the narrow
melon and
staining um on the right there
[Music]
is observed by after five weeks and
mercury goes into how we kind of
optimize
this to get this expression which is
quite early compared to other examples
of
organoid protocols
so fine okay so finally in conclusion um
suspension culture differentiation
protocols were introduced for generating
nfcs midbrain dopaminergic neurons
cardiomyocyte steroids and midbrain
organoids
from stem scale psv and
significant benefits we're seeing when
comparing suspension culture protocols
to
monolayer including shortened protocol
length
less hands-on time and improved
expansion yields
key parameters for optimizing for
optimization including psc
size duration of differentiation steps
as well as
agitation rates and medium volumes
and the efficient nucleation
and uniform size of spheroids cultured
in stem scale
promotes efficient and uniform
differentiation
as well as flexibility during the
optimization
of these differentiation protocols and
again application notes and protocols
and more details can all be found
online at thermofisher.com stem scale
and that is one of my talk thank you
very much elaborate for
having us and letting us present and
we can take as many
questions as time allows thank you
thank you gentlemen for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question is
oh
here we go do you keep rock when
performing the medium change
um so when performing the media exchange
uh we only add
a rock inhibitor on day zero during
seeding so no rock inhibitor will be
included
um when removing media and replacing
with fresh media uh you only need to add
the rock inhibitor on day zero during
seeding
okay great thank you and our next
question
what is the effect of the spheroid
dissociation on the cells
are the cells stressed after counting
um so when we use accutanes to
disassociate the spheroids
uh the disassociation uh involving
accutase is gentle on the cells
um so there's no stress that will affect
their viability
and we we've seen that viability is
affected more you know like if you pass
cell through a cell strainer
due to the cells essentially being
sheared apart uh and with that few
tastes
provided that you're performing the
passaging stuff in a timely manner
there will be no issues you can also
choose to add rock inhibitor
uh when you're resuspending the cells
for counting to improve their health
um oh and also we've seen that when you
scale up to large volumes
the amount of accutase and the duration
of the acetate's exposure
will need to increase as well and for
three liter cultures uh we've had them
in accutase between 20 to 25 minutes to
break apart all the spheroids
and those have still been able to go
into subsequent passages with no issues
um so when using accutase it's a nice
gentle
passaging reagent
okay thank you michael and our next
question
have you tested the pluripotency of
higher passages
p50 to 70 for instance
um no we have not tested uh beyond 30
passages
um for pluripotency or expansion
um we did want to provide data
indicating the stability of the cells
grown in stem scale over like a longer
period of time as opposed to just simply
scaling up
so users can choose to maintain their
cells for long term as opposed to
scaling up
but we would not recommend culturing a
particular line for a significantly long
period of time
similar to what you would do when
treating like your hearing cultures for
example
okay great thank you so much and we have
another question coming in
so will the recommended shaker speed 70
rpm work universally or
does it need to be adjusted depending on
the shaker kind or culture vessel of
choice
oh yes so the recommended shaker rpm of
70 rpm
that i gave in this presentation uh is
not universal and will need to be
adjusted
uh depending on a number of different uh
variables
so if you're using uh the recommended uh
the thermal fischer brand orbital shaker
that was in this presentation then 70
rpm will work
because that's what we use for our
evaluations but otherwise if you have a
different
type of orbital shaker platform then you
will need to convert to a different rpm
based on the orbital diameter of our
thermo fissure brand orbital shaker
and the orbital shaker that you are
using and we do have the um
orbital diameter of the thermo shaker
listed in the stem scale faq
so you can go look that up and perform
on a calculation using an equation as
well listed in the faq
um and also if you're using uh like
different sized flasks or well plates
then you need to balance the volume in
the flask
with the rpm that you're using and so at
the 70 rpm listed in this presentation
we have a number of different volumes
for the different sized vessels
in the stem scale manual that will work
but if you want to work outside of this
rpm or outside of the recommended
volumes
then you'll need to do some adjusting to
determine the correct balance between
rpm
and volume
all right great thank you so much and
thanks to the audience for so many great
questions we have a lot of
amazing questions coming in so our next
question
how do you check if some differentiation
appears in your culture of ipscs
um so this this can be a little more
difficult with the spheroids
compared to adherent culture but i'd say
for a quick assessment
looking at their morphology is a good
measure because after day one
once the steroids have rounded up into a
nice uniform
morphology uh if any differentiation is
occurring uh you'll see
their morphology is actually more uneven
um and it will not appear to be as
perfectly spherical as
all the images you've seen in this
presentation
great thank you again for that amazing
answer and our next question
uh do you know uh let's see oh i'm sorry
i skipped one
can self-aggregating spheroids be
transformed into organoids
greatly enhancing the understanding of
disease processes as well as aiding
faster and more efficient drug testing
and discoveries
um yeah this is uh michael there i'll
take this one um
yes we we did show some some midbrain
organoid work that we've done and um
indeed uh these stem scale psc spheroid
aggregates are compatible with with uh
organoid generation um some
and again there's uh a lab roots webinar
on that by and richard josephson that
was mentioned in the
presentation um but additionally some of
our
our internal work um we've had good
success with
uh generating cortical neurons as well
from these
um self-aggregating
psd spheroids so they definitely are
compatible
and those those are the two that we've
had
success with so far
thank you michael and we've got another
question
do you know why the starting size makes
this significant difference in the da
specification efficiency
um yeah that's that's a good question um
i mean i think it's
it could be a different uh it could be a
manner of
sort of two different variables um
different differentiation protocols um
are going to require optimization
of the sphere size in in that particular
case
um it may be due to either
[Music]
signaling molecule penetration so maybe
the
the larger size decreases the
penetration of
the differentiation um i guess molecules
important for differentiating during
specification
the other one could be sort of just the
morphology
of the differentiating
cell aggregates during specification so
um
each uh at least the ones that we've
tested each differentiation protocol the
the morphology seems to be a little bit
different during
um specifications or during the initial
differentiation process
whatever that may be and this could have
impacts on
also media penetration or
just how well they take on
the um the
agitation rate um and
other things so so it could be a
morphology thing where
um maybe if you adjusted some of the
the agitation rates or the medium
volumes
the larger sizes may work um
so there's there's a few things to to
consider when you're optimizing the
differentiation protocol
great thank you again and we've got time
for a few more questions
do you provide any training for handling
3d cultures of ipscs
um so we do have some uh training videos
that are available
on the the stem scale page uh and i
believe that uh there's also
um the option for a more hands-on option
um that can be scheduled as well
although it might be more virtual these
days
like everything else right
okay we've got a few more questions um
can i use a passaging
uh reagent other than stem pro accutase
um yes so you can use a different
passaging region as well
if you would like to although the
results are going to be a little
different
um like for example if you try to use a
passaging reagent like
uh versing um but since the the
spheroids aren't being broken down into
single cells
um there's going to be a lot more size
variability when you go into your
subsequent passage
so yeah we don't recommend the clump um
packaging region for this reason
uh you would have to probably use the
sill strainer in order to break them
down further
and if you try to use another single
cell passaging reagent such as
triple select triple is actually a
little more harsh
than stem pro accutase
and so this causes some nice dna to
remain in the culture when you
seed your your cells for a subsequent
passage
and then this causes undesirable
aggregation and you get
some clumps of cells instead of nice
spheroidal aggregates
so if you're using triple select then
you'll probably have to add
some dna to your culture in order to
prevent that from occurring
so this is why we recommend stem proxy
paste since it's
gentle and it doesn't require any
additional steps
and i have time for one more question
are other types of rock inhibitors
compatible with stem scale
yes so in the presentation i mentioned
we recommend using
y27632 but you can use other rock
inhibitors
we've tested um four or five different
rock inhibitors and found that
as long as you have a rock inhibitor
present then the cells will uh aggregate
the spheroids
but in terms of the best performance the
y27 um
has the best nucleation and results in
the best sized spheroids by the end of
the culture period so we would still
recommend
proceeding with y27632
great thank you again both of you
michael aikenhead and michael durr
do you have any final comments for our
audience before we go
um well i'd like to thank you for
listening to the presentation
and uh for providing such uh great
questions
yeah same for me thank you for all the
great questions and
thank you lavreats for having us present
as well thank you
well thank you again michael aikenhead
and michael durer for your time today
and for your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast before we go i'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye